at home another round of mountain snow  and valley rain talking about that gust  we are under a wind advisory all the way  until tomorrow checking out your gusts  for you las vegas you can see southwest  winds staying 16 miles per hour gusting  all the way up to 24. we will continue  to track those gusts and those  temperatures dropping into the cooler  40s notice we have shower chances  kicking in around that 7 p.m hour 52  degrees we'll eventually drop conditions  around 11 p.m with 46 degrees cloudy  conditions and we do expect another  chance for rain after midnight here's a  look at that wind advisory we talked  about it will expire tomorrow at 3 a.m  and coming up we'll talk more about  those strong south southwest winds that  look to taper off by tuesday morning  before we could see that next storm  system kicking in bringing us more  chances for rain mountain snow and  colder temperatures back to you brian